I'm so excited for your new show, "I Love That For You".
And Molly Shannon was just here.
Yes, yes.
Who is so incredible
in this show.
I'm really glad that you two are doing this show together.
Yes, thank you.
That's what we all need right now,
in the world.
Thank you.
And maybe a little of this to go with it,
while we're watching a little bit comedy,
a little bit of comfort.
So there's a new food trend, everybody.
And people write into the show
and they ask us to do a review,
but I'm gonna hand it over to Vanessa,
even though it's called Drew's Reviews,
Vanessa's gonna do the review.
So it's Drew's Reviews, with Vanessa Bayer!
(audience cheers and applauds)
So something got invented called the pizza cupcake.
Wow, wow.
I'm here for it.
I love pizza and I love cupcakes,
so this feels like a dream come true.
(audience laughs)
Like I don't wanna,
I don't wanna be rude, so I wanna...
Oh, actually, the center comes out.
Okay, these are...
Oh my God.
(audience laughs)
I mean, my whole middle came out, but it's really good.
That's the best part.
You managed to
cut yours with your teeth.
That's awesome.
I've got very sharp teeth.
You should put that in your dating app.
Yeah. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
(both laugh)
Look, Vanessa, thoughts?
Okay, well, um.
(Drew mumbles)
I think if you had to
sum it up in one word,
it would be more pizza than cupcake.
I think if you know what you're getting into
you're gonna love it.
But if you're,
(audience laughs)
but if you're expecting a cupcake, you're gonna go,
"Well..."
(audience laughs)
You know.
Not that.
I mean, I'll keep eating it
just like you are.
I've been eating really a lot of food today.
So I'm just like...
Well, how many stars would you give this, Vanessa?
I would give it four stars and here's why.
Oh that's actually, that's pretty nice.
Yeah, I think it's pretty,
I think it's pretty good.
It's pretty tasty.
But I think it's misleading that cupcake is in the title,
because I really,
even if you saw like, just to get...
Okay.
Even if you saw this, you'd go,
"Oh that's a little piece of bread with a pepperoni on it."
You wouldn't necessarily go like, "Oh, a cupcake!"
You know, there's gonna be a lot of cupcake fans going,
"Not my day."
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
Sorry.
Look how we got forks.
Like what if...
And neither of us ever were like, "Oh, we should..."
(audience laughs)
Maybe that's why we're not having luck,
'cause we're not little,
we're not like little ladies who go like, "Oh."
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
Look at my plate.
I took out the center.
It's, oh my God.
Every one.
I think, I mean that's...
You know what?
I don't care, you know what I want?
Funny.
I want people who put stuff out there in the world
and make all of our lives better
by putting smiles on our faces
(audience applauds)
and making us laugh
and producing material that's gonna brighten our day.
Yes, I agree!
That's what I want.
That's what I want too.
Put that on my app.
Vanessa Bayer.
"I Love That For You" is available to watch today,
on streaming and on demand.
That's right, it's premiere day.
It's dropped, it's hot
and it airs Sunday night on Showtime.
I love you so much.
You too.
This was so much fun.
(audience applauds)
Screw the app.
Yeah, we don't need that.
Yeah, exactly, I'm like, meh.
(audience cheers and applauds)
So good to meet you.
This is a match.
This is a match!
And we're all a match.
(bright theme music)